[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana de radio
france internacional y france 24 esta
semana ponemos el foco en la otan la
organización trasatlántica del atlántico
norte que celebra el 29 y 30 de junio su
cumbre en madrid una cita fundamental en
un momento clave con el trasfondo de la
guerra de ucrania nos acompañan para
analizar el presente y el futuro de la
otan en este estudio luis rivas
periodista independiente ex
corresponsable moscú bienvenido a louis
y hacer luz nos acompaña también maría
josé zorrilla y politóloga encargada de
la misión en la presidencia francesa del
consejo de la unión europea bienvenida
maríajosé benquerencia carlos y en
dúplex fernando hernández holgado
historiador docente de la complutense de
madrid- autor del libro historia de la
otan de la guerra fría al
intervencionismo humanitario buenos días
señor hernández buenos días pues muchas
gracias por la invitación y es un placer
estar con vosotras aunque sea
virtualmente y espero estar un poco a la
altura del compromiso por supuesto que
sí presente y futuro de la otan en un
momento clave de la historia hoy en
primera
[Música]
la invasión rusa de ucrania marca la
cumbre de la otan que se va a celebrar
en madrid los próximos 29 y 30 de junio
la solicitud de adhesión de suecia y
finlandia a la alianza atlántica estará
sobre la mesa siempre que turquía
levante su actual veto el papel de la
otan en el conflicto ucraniano es
importante pues proporciona seguridad a
países limítrofes que se sienten
amenazados y que pertenecen a la alianza
como es el caso de bulgaria polonia o
los países bálticos tan sólo tres años
después de que mccrone dijese aquello de
que la otan estaba en situación de
muerte cerebral ha llegado putin para
reavivar su sentido y para aumentar la
alianza quizás el efecto contrario del
que hubiese deseado repasamos algunas
portadas de new statesman plantea en
esta portada el duelo entre putin y la
otan afirmando que la alianza está de
regreso aquí en francia el juego
internacional se pregunta en esta
portada sobre un fondo con los colores
de la bandera ucraniana si la paz es aún
posible y la prense pregunta en este
artículo porque finlandia quiere unirse
a la otan tras décadas de neutralidad y
con una opinión pública que ahora sí
mayoritariamente
respalda esa adhesión bueno en la guerra
de putin ha revitalizado la otan
podremos decir eso cuando se puede decir
si vemos los hechos y porque desde macro
no el presidente francés se hablaba de
muerte federal de la otan a hoy como en
cambio de las cosas ha cambiado las
cosas en el sentido de que incluso hay
más miembros que quieren entrar como
finlandia o suecia pero poniéndose en el
lugar de vladimir putin el presidente
ruso habría que pensar también su fin es
que ucrania no entra en la otan es decir
desde la caída del muro y de la
desaparición de la unión soviética ha
habido tres oleadas de ampliación a la
otan catorce países han entrado y
rodeando a rusia la actual rusia quiero
decir para putin
la clave es ucrania si hay otros países
que van a entrar por supuesto que no
será positivo para él pero él
interpretando que la posición de la
guerra fría para él es la actualidad es
lo que es
lo que se bebía lo que se vivía antes yo
creo que es y es la clave este ucrania
entre la otan
esto ya es menos importante podemos
decir que pudiera revitalizado la otan y
la cumbre los días que vienen en madrid
si definitivamente pero creo que no
solamente la otan sino todos diferentes
instituciones europeas como la unión
europea el consejo europeo porque desde
que justamente este conflicto nuclear
han empezado han habido muchísimas más
cumbres más conferencias más reuniones
que tratan no solamente este conflicto
en ucrania sino diferentes temas como la
seguridad europea es que se debe tener
por ejemplo una una milicia europea el
financiamiento etcétera y creo que
justamente todo esto se refleja también
en el liderazgo que puede tener macro o
que intenta tener macrón dentro en
europea y eso se va a ver en las
próximas semanas que justamente macrón
tiene una última conferencia para la
presidencia del consejo europeo como
dijiste también tiene la próxima semana
una reunión una cumbre madrid entonces
creo que tiene que ver mucho vamos a ver
bastante qué posición va a tomar macro
como líder posible el líder lo de un
europeo pero también de otros países
otros bloques como alemania reino unido
un macro en que termina su mandato de
semestral en la unión europea con esa
candidatura precisamente de ucrania que
se acaba de aprobar según el consejo de
bruselas pero al que tiene en cuenta
también que es una candidatura es verdad
que sí pero también hay que tener en
cuenta que hablando de el desarrollo de
otras organizaciones yo creo que la
ampliación de la otan y las fuerzas de
la otan también puede jugar jugar contra
esa europa
militar y esa europa de la defensa que
precisamente macrón buscaba porque hay
que ser claro la otan es una
organización dirigida por eeuu donde los
miembros compran armamento de eeuu y en
europeo con lo cual
hay que verlo desde dos puntos de vista
que es la ampliación de la otan es
también volver a la potencia militar de
eeuu en europa y por lo tanto va a ser
muy difícil que después de eso europa
sea independiente desde el punto de
vista defensivo hay como una vuelta a la
guerra fría a esa sensación de los
bloques que se quedaron en la guerra
fría que queríamos haber sobrepasado
pero que con la guerra de ucrania
vuelven de nuevo a lado al panorama
pero yo creo que también como dice luis
está como injerencia de nuevo
estadounidense en europa también se
explica un poco por la fuente de
financiamiento de la otan o sea eeuu
destina 7% del pib para justamente en
materia
militar armamento mientras que países
como por ejemplo españa o francia
solamente sina 12 por ciento de su
pendiente alguna vez eeuu lo ha
criticado esto la falta de financiación
de otros socios recuerdo que en dúplex
tenemos contamos con fernando hernández
holgado historiador docente de la
complutense de madrid autor de historia
de la otan de la guerra fría el
intervencionismo humanitario señores
stoltenberg ya ha dicho que la cumbre de
madrid de la otan va a ser muy
importante qué perspectivas tiene usted
de lo que pueda salir de la cumbre de
madrid una cita que hace unos meses
hubiese sido regular y que en cambio
ahora ha tomado esa gran vitalidad está
de acuerdo no creo que vaya a ser una
cumbre muy importante en términos
globales dado el veto que sigue
manteniendo turquía al ingreso de suecia
y finlandia y hoy por hoy para lo que sí
que va a servir es para escenificar
digamos el apoyo de la organización del
tratado del atlántico norte al actual
gobierno ucraniano sí que es verdad que
a nivel interno español
esta cumbre va a tener digamos unas
resonancias internas y indicio de la
importancia de esta cumbre a nivel
interno eso es por ejemplo las sospechas
que se vertieron en hace unas semanas
acerca del giro dado por la política de
envío de ar política española de envío
de armas a ucrania en un principio no
iban a enviar armas pero de la noche a
la mañana
decidieron hacerlo lo cual ha generado
ciertas tensiones en la coalición
gobernante y cunden sospechas de que ese
cambio tan repentino decisión ha podido
obedecer precisamente a presiones de la
otan con vistas a esta cumbre de madrid
es decir no habría estado bien visto de
la organización anfitriona de esta
cumbre
si hubiese opuesto al enviado de armas
se hubiese mantenido un perfil bajo en
relación con el apoyo político y militar
al actual gobierno de ucrania
beto de turquía louis que va a pesar
pero bueno también cumbre importante
como enseña la del profesor para el país
organizador para españa con esa especie
de giro que nos explica el profesor
hernández en la coalición si dos cosas
primero o turquía es el digamos la oveja
negra de la otan porque es muy
importante del punto de vista
estratégico pero ya tomar decisiones
como por ejemplo comprar el sistema
antimisiles ruso y no en el
norteamericano después ayuda por otra
parte con los drones a ucrania y ayuda
por otra parte con drones a enemigos en
teoría de rusia también como como los
nombra varias bandas así y además es
tiene una rivalidad histórica con grecia
que es otros dos miembros de la otan
importante no pero yo creo que no va a
bloquear pero a negociar como siempre
hacen y para más por cuestiones internas
se tiene elecciones año que viene su
economía va muy mal y puede perder
elecciones y en cuanto a españa que
tiene en cuenta un poco la historia el
gobierno español es un gobierno de
izquierdas donde hay número de sistema
izquierda ya el partido socialista se
oponía la uta en los años 80 hasta que
decidieron entrar
porque estaban obligados también a ello
si querían integrarse en europa pero hay
un miembros de extrema izquierda como
podemos como otros partidos en el
gobierno español apoyando y ellos
mantienen está digamos antia norte
mercanismo y se oponen al envío de armas
y digamos también a no es un apoyo pero
digamos que no entran en este en esta
campaña anti rusa ese sentir
americanismo ésta ha sido siempre la
raíz que ha estado en contra de los
argumentos esgrimidos contra la otan
tanto desde posiciones progresistas como
también desde posiciones conservadoras
que también hayan tenido americanismo en
europa sobre todo en francia y sobre
todo en francia para jose esto lo
veíamos cuando españa
entró de la otan pero lo que vemos ahora
son países que se han mantenido con
mucha neutralidad hasta ahora como el
caso de suecia como finlandia y que
ahora sus opiniones públicas
mayoritariamente dicen que sí que
perciben la amenaza que quieren entrar
en el club
y definitivamente esto más recordar a
una editorial de le monde que decía que
justamente no hablan tanto de una
de una neutralidad sino más bien de un
quizás alineamientos acerca hacia una
posición igual claro me parece
interesante que quizá para nosotros en
general vemos de afuera a la otan como
un bloque pero realmente dentro de la
otan hay como diferentes posiciones con
respecto a diferentes temas por ejemplo
como decía sobre el conflicto en ucrania
tenemos españa y francia que tiene como
una posición más de diálogo de
conversación mientras por ejemplo eeuu
el reino unido tiene una posición más
como confrontación al volvemos en este
punto con fernando hernández holgado
historiador como podría señor hernández
responder la otan ante un eventual uso
de armas nucleares o químicas por parte
de rusia
y yo creo que en una guerra de larga o
mediaproducción proyección en marcha que
es lo que parece ser que se está
apuntando en ucrania al último que le
conviene al gobierno ruso es
desencadenar un ataque de este tipo
y en este sentido creo que la otan
practica un juego ambivalente con esta
presunta amenaza la idea para justificar
su implicación
bien entendido que se trata de una
implicación a distancia es decir su
implicación mediante el envío de armas
pero tampoco desea generar un excesivo
alarmismo que pudiera comprometer la y
escalar por tanto el conflicto hasta
proporciones indeseables lo que podíamos
terminar una hecatombe nuclear con lo
cual la otan ahora mismo está
midiendo un poco está dosificando
digamos esa amenaza cuando se trata de
publicitarla y hay que recordar aquí los
riesgos de empleo de armas químicas y
nucleares tácticas esos riesgos fueron
recurrentes durante las diversas guerras
calientes entre comillas de la guerra
fría antes de korea los años 50 están
cola en los años 80
en aquel entonces ya los dos bloques
enfrentados de la guerra fría se
acostumbraron a encapsular los
conflictos ya dosificar el grado de
destrucción de cada uno es decir era
posible bombardear en vietnam por
ejemplo por parte del ejército
estadounidense
poblaciones civiles en 1970 con naval o
agente naranja y a nivel internacional
mantener relaciones diplomáticas
colonias soviética en el marco de una
supuesta distensión ya sabéis que el
periodo de la distensión de la detente
abarca del año 62 al 75 y se daba por
descartada de manera inmediata una
hecatombe nuclear pero se estaba
desarrollando y se estaban implementando
esfuerzos muy muy importantes en una
guerra en una guerra convencional una
guerra caliente como fue la del vietnam
que ya sabemos que duró casi del año 63
64 se realice científico en resumen me
quedo con este concepto que nos comenta
el profesor hernández la otan está
dosificando esa amenaza calibrando la la
tiene en cuenta sin ser alarmista a la
vuelta de pausa les pregunto por ello
hasta ahora
[Música]
liberté égalité actual y t
enlace del conosur a norteamérica de los
andes' a centroamérica una cita semanal
con los temas más importantes de los
países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
france 24
enlace en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
seguimos en primera plana esta semana
analizando la otan con la cumbre de
madrid estos días que vienen el 29 y el
30 y lo estamos analizando desde la
perspectiva de si putin ha revitalizado
a la alianza del atlántico norte lo
hacemos con el periodista luís rivas
maría josé zorrilla politóloga y
fernando hernández holgado historiador
desde la complutense de madrid e
historiador gran conocedor de la otan
muchos expertos mantienen que estamos
viviendo la peor crisis en las
relaciones otan-rusia desde antes de la
del fin de la guerra fría la anexión
ilegal de crimea en 2014 por las fuerzas
rusas contra el principio de
inviolabilidad de las fronteras y la
soberanía de los países dentro de sus
fronteras trajo un cambio importante en
la relación entre la otan y rusia que
habían sido cordiales hasta entonces
esta deriva de putin louis nos ha
devuelto a la guerra fría no sé si está
de acuerdo con lo que comentaba antes de
la pausa el profesor hernández que la
otan estaría dosificando esta amenaza
calibrando la
bueno es el momento de enseñar los
músculos la otan enseña músculo y está
esperando que la guerra de ucrania les
sirva también para ampliar los miembros
es un momento para ellos
aprovechando una guerra se puede decidir
positivo para la otan pero de lo que se
trata es de que esta guerra un día va a
acabar y cómo va a acabar voy a decir yo
no creo en las amenazas nucleares en la
utilización de armas químicas sino que
rusia va a llevar sus alabanzas y sus
tropas hasta cierto punto donde después
se negocie quiero decir la otan lo que
está haciendo es intentando armar a
ucrania lo más posible para que rusia
avance lo menos posible pero se llegará
un momento en que habrá una paz una paz
negociada en esa paz negociada
habrá que tener en cuenta también los
intereses de las dos partes tendrán que
ceder y ahí entra esa polémica que
surgió con sergio cuando el presidente
macrón dijo que no había que humillar a
rusia
lo que quería decir que el supuesto
claro a
distancia que debe venir de lenski el
presidente ucraniano toman un invasor y
hay que verificarlo y es pudieron por
supuesto pero a la hora de negociar pues
se negocia una paz y hay que tiene en
cuenta también que hemos vivido en el
olvido en el siglo pasado también en
situaciones las tropas soviéticas
adentro en checoslovaquia dentro en
hungría
han ocupado que decir ha lanzado la
asistencia del gobierno polaco quiere
decir hemos vivido historias muy graves
ahora es una guerra mucho que
mediáticamente es mucho más fuerte
porque hay muchos más medios y también
emocionalmente también jose
yo soy acuerdo con lo que está diciendo
luis definitivamente al final de la
guerra al final de una guerra no
solamente va a haber un ganador y un
vencido creo que al final siempre va a
haber negociaciones de ambos lados y me
parece bastante sensato lo bueno la
postura que están tomando ciertos
ciertos dirigentes como por ejemplo como
estamos conversando macro aunque
justamente intente sopesar esto los
poderes se consideraban muchas críticas
por esas frases
envidian que el comportamiento
interracial de rusia ha creado un cambio
estructural sistémico donde la guerra am
híbrida como lo llaman ahora y la
proyección de inestabilidad global están
ganando relevancia es decir ha cambiado
todo lo que pensábamos que era nuestro
el concepto que a lo mejor nuestra
generación tenía de guerra una
generación que no había vivido la guerra
sí pero es que inevitablemente prohíbe
un avance tecnológico también un avance
tecnológico significa que la guerra no
se hace solamente con tanques aunque no
se hace porque el armamento que se está
enviando a ucrania desde europa de eeuu
es arma son tanques y son obuses y son
misiles pero también es una ciberguerra
quiere decir se va a utilizar todos los
medios posibles pero en ese en esa
guerra intervienen todos no solamente
rusia sino también todos los que se
enfrentan a rusia también por supuesto
fernando profesor hernández holgado
desde la complutense madrid hagamos un
poco de historia porque estamos
comentando que hace tres años dijo el
presión de macrón que la otan estaba en
estado de muerte cerebral
era los principales problemas que
arrastraba la alianza eran sobre todo
financieros bueno si seguimos haciendo
un poquito de historia esta más
inmediata y pensemos que ese estado de
muerte cerebral que dijo no chrome se
explicaba fijaos sí muy interesante
porque el propio presidente de eeuu en
aquel entonces nuestra 2017 al 2021
desconfiaba de la alianza y criticaba
incluso la propia supervivencia de la
alianza de la alianza militar al tiempo
que presionaba con poco éxito para que
los propios socios aumentaran el gasto
militar realmente tiene entonces quien
estaba en estado de muerte cerebral
quizá la otan pero también estaba el
propio presente atrás trump desconfiaba
de la alianza eso generó una crisis
tremenda porque la alianza se configura
a partir de la columna vertebral de eeuu
y de la estructura militar de la alianza
que está presidida por eeuu y ahora
precisamente eeuu quien estaba
cuestionando la alianza pero fijémonos
que trump en aquel entonces lo que
estaba haciendo al mismo tiempo era
quejarse de que los socios europeos de
la alianza
estaba lo suficiente en el gasto militar
esto es interesante porque si algo ha
hecho la otan durante todo este tiempo
del año 49 es presionar al alza al gasto
militar esta presión al alza de los
gastos del armamento es importantísima
porque fijémonos vamos más allá de
retóricas más o menos pacifistas
etcétera o de amenazas o alarmistas
vamos a fijarnos quién está haciendo
negocio aquí mientras evidentemente sólo
hablamos de las grandes empresas
occidentales de armamento la otan carece
de recursos propios una realidad es una
especie de club militar un gigantesco
lobby de tremenda influencia sobre las
políticas de los o de los países socios
tanto sobre las políticas exteriores a
nivel de política exterior o las
relaciones internacionales como sobre
sus políticas de defensa y esto se
traduce precisamente esto explica esta
insistencia en el aumento en el aumento
del gasto militar y ahora lo que estamos
viendo precisamente con ocasión del
conflicto crear ya no es otra vez un
nuevo momento esta vez mucho más
importante en términos cualitativos que
que lo que quiere experimentado hasta el
momento
jose le parece lo que estaba contando el
profesor hernández de esa necesidad del
gasto militar pero también de la
industria que detrás de cómo la otan
influyen las políticas de esos miembros
del club no sí por supuesto yo creo que
también hay como un transtorno
transfondo económico además de político
militar comercial claro y entonces
tenemos que preguntarnos quién al final
es el que sale ganando quién es el grupo
de persona de quién es el grupo que sale
ganando tras este conflicto
louis a europa a muchos países de europa
pero sobre todo a europa no le
interesaba antes de la guerra no le
interesaba en absoluto
aumentar las sanciones contra rusia y
empeorar las relaciones con rusia es
decir solamente cuando
se ha visto una guerra real cuando se
han visto víctimas cuando se han visto
imágenes de niños y de identidades
destruidas lo que es una guerra de
verdad y mediáticamente súper cubierta
cuando se ven obligados un poco también
a ceder en sus posiciones decir pero
digamos que la ruptura psicológica para
los políticos europeos
de reducir sus relaciones con moscú es
brutal por desde todo punto de vista del
punto de vista energético del punto de
vista comercial y del punto vista
también de relaciones de todo tipo
porque durante tanto tiempo la opinión
pública ha sido tan crítica en algunos
países occidentales respecto a este tipo
de alianzas y luego de repente tiene que
llegar un episodio como el de ucrania
para concienciarnos de que el mundo no
es ideal de que no es como deseamos que
hay que afrontar los gastos en defensa
no tienen esa sensación que a veces las
opiniones públicas funcionan no de una
forma racional sino a golpe de este tipo
de yo creo que al principio era porque
había un problema de legitimidad que
sufría la otan y pero no solamente eso
sino varias diferentes organizaciones
internacionales tienen este problema de
legitimidad con respecto a los
ciudadanos a las personas con las que
están realmente deben estar conectadas
pero también creo que es como
comentábamos anteriormente hay como una
cierta crisis o una cierta manera llevar
este conflicto en los medios entonces
eso también va
definitivamente a jugar un rol
importante dentro de ese conflicto la
posición que pueden tener los medios
dentro de cómo se va a llevar la
problemática al final cuando termine la
guerra va a ser quien justamente
narrativa va a sopesar exacto es muy
importante antes lo comentaba mi
compañero luís de pasada más allá de las
posibles ampliaciones otro de los
grandes asuntos que se manejan en el
seno de la otan es el de la
ciberseguridad en julio de 2016 los
aliados reconocieron el ciberespacio
como dominio operacional donde la otan
debe defenderse
esta es la gran tarea louis del presente
y el futuro de la otan
bueno no sólo porque es una vertiente
más de la guerra pero si luego si vemos
la realidad que decir
tan importante es la ciberseguridad como
la como los tanques como los misiles con
los sistemas antimisiles como los
cañones es decir todo todo todo el
armamento militar que se está
desarrollando precisamente por la
potestad para esta guerra de una
industria militar que estaba
digamos no paralizada pero que estaba
iba poco a poco a las habidas para decir
la ciberseguridad es importante pero las
armas reales y tangibles también les
preguntó bueno en caso de que no nos
guste la otan y qué alternativas hay a
la otan ese plan de tan a veces
considerado como utópico del ejército
común europeo cuáles serían las
alternativas si no la regia por el
momento yo no veo que hubiera alguna
alguna otra alternativa realmente el
león europea no nos especialista
justamente en esto en velar por
justamente la seguridad militar de los
países y bien si hay un artículo dentro
de la constitución europea y todo esto
que habla sobre igual al igual que el
artículo 5 de la otan que si un estado
es
agredido por otro entonces todos los
demás estados miembros van a estar a su
apoyo por el momento me parece que la
otan es como un mal necesario sí porque
hay llamamientos desde ciertos países de
europa ese ejército común pero luego
falta convicción o voluntad política en
el fondo para ir adelante para dar pasos
en ese sentido
definitivamente y financiamiento y
financiamiento louis como velas
alternativas si es que las hay
en primer lugar lo que es que la defensa
europea ahora mismo es la otan claro y
la defensa europea está en manos de eeuu
digamos lo que estamos viendo ahora lo
que hablamos antes se puede considerar
también como la victoria a donald trump
y de eeuu que pedían más inversiones en
armas y más inversiones cada país pero
también es verdad también que europa
está dividida o sea no es lo mismo estar
ser un metido en el país báltico de
polonia claro que en portugal o españa
por ejemplo que está muy lejos de las
fronteras y hay que tener en cuenta que
si ya está digamos esta guerra en que
comenzó y que
tiene tanto resonancia mediática las
opiniones públicas yo no creo que si se
hace un referendo una hora esté todo el
mundo en europa y dependiendo de qué
países por continuar este tipo de
armamento también a ucrania decir hay
alguna simpatía por el sufrimiento de un
pueblo por supuesto pero no significa
que todos los europeos apoyen a la otan
lo que significativo es que países como
suecia o finlandia que eran
neutrales hasta ahora de repente tenemos
unas opiniones públicas movilizadas en
más del 70% a la visión en el club de la
amenaza es limítrofe y ha tenido ya dos
guerras con rusia en el siglo 20 y sabe
muy bien lo que puede ser y además están
recibiendo la presión por ejemplo de la
otan y todo sobre los aliados de la otan
pero suiza no por ejemplo pues es un
placer tenerles hoy con todos nosotros
muchísimas gracias
mara josé zorrilla politóloga encargada
de la misión de la presidencia francesa
del consejo de la unión europea mi
compañero luis rivas periodista
independiente que fue corresponsal en
moscú y por eso conoce también este tema
y fernando hernández holgado en nuestro
historiador de desde la universidad
complutense de madrid y a todos ustedes
les esperamos la próxima semana quien en
primera plana gracias
[Música]